(pewds screams in fear of copyright strikes)
The rule is-a simple, everybody. Say it with me, aha-: YOU LAUGH, YOU LOSE!
Say it... say- say it!
SAY IT
pewds ?? wtf
Now, last one got taken down.
From a copyright strike. Two of them.
I don't really know why I bother even making these!
All the effort on editing and trying to make it my own.
It's completely pointless.
This video will probably be deleted as well. So really the challenge is: you get copyright striked? You lose.
Like youtube isn't hard enough these days? What the *duck* am I doing? I'm a struggling youtuber now.
This is what happened.
(in high voice) But you brought this on yourself pewds!
You're goddamn right I did. You're welcome.
Let's do this. You laugh, you lose. All right. What do we got here? What, she's trying to do this advanced equation?
248 minus 200 (208)- oh plus. That's 6,000? (?? what)
Oh my god... oh my *starts l a u g h i n g*
She did it! *laughs more*
*asthma seizure* wtf poods
Well, she was close, to be fair. She just gotta...
she gi, she uhhh, she forgot to add the, the one to the four, it's, uh...
It's pretty cute. It's kind of like the people that mix up spelling- spelling you and you're.
introducing another
with your new personal assistant
Alexa Jones. Whatever you need, all you have to do is ask Alexa Jones. Well. What does it do?
Alexa what do you do? (Alex Jones) teach people about the sexual pleasure of eating turds.
SCANNING! ZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZZcontrolZZZZZZZZZ manipulate scientific data *special effects*
TAKEOVER. BLAST. CONTROL. WORLD GOVERMENT
SHUT DOWN INFRASTRUCTURE *more special effects* SHIP EVERYTHING TO CHINA
*homemade special effects*
Look at this person.
Love Alex Jones, but like
What the f. *duck*
AHAAAAAA *anime boobs*
Virgins of the world
Lend me your virginity
wait that works?
*pewds raises hands in acceptance of who he truly is*
creaTE MY VIRGIN BALL
Was that Dragon Ball Z?
What an amaZING ANIME, I NEED TO WATCH IT.
In order to feel inserted this is what you face. Me, or your genetic test. (Pewds) What is happening?
Face your annihilation *screaming*
Wait, what is this?
He puts it puts it on a cow. Oh, okay. That's cool
*wheeze*
Eyyhehehehe
Ohohhh nooo
Need to play that game again
God damn it the gif from it is amazing.
Medieval castles were not easy to break into, they were basically like those jungle gym things at Chuck-E-Cheese's, massive in size
intentionally confusing layout
Security everywhere and by the end of your visit you probably end up with some kind of disease so in order to help penetrate
fortresses medieval armies would often utilize siege weapons one of the most popular of which was the
Trebuchet now this device is interesting enough on its own, but it gets better so around 1300 ad king
WTF is this?
of England was in the process of invading scotland however one fortress known as
Stirling castle was giving him a lot of trouble
He laid siege to the building for many months without any real progress then one day
He woke up and had a revelation hey guys listen
Why are we wasting our time and building all these regular sized?
Ricochets where we could just build one giant one and call it a day
so that's what he did this gargantuan war machine was known as the war wolf and stood at around 6 stories tall to give a
bit of perspective
This is about as tall as king Kong was in his largest film depiction so basically picture a giant *duck* ape
Launching Boulders like they're baseballs
And you've got a pretty good idea of what the war wolf was capable of. it was so intimidating
That when the scots saw the English constructing the beasts outside the castle
They immediately surrendered out of fear, but then edward was like
Huh that I'm gonna test this bad boy out and proceeded to take Potshots on the castle any
See we need this is the stuff we need happening.
there's too many passive aggressive people on social media because no one's out killing each other
How to make a blockbuster, okay?
Have you ever wondered about this particular thing?
Because it turns out that that thing is real
All right, I get it. They're all the same
oh... omae wa... classic.
omae wa mo shinde iru. NANI?!
great
What has happened? ENDLESS TRASH! okay great
Think I've just lost the ability to laugh
Can I give you a list of historical figures prominent figures from history and you'll tell me whether or not they were white or black?
-Shoot, give me your best shot.
-Where do we start... okay um
-Beethoven?
-Black.
-Mozart?
-Cleopatra?
-She looked black, but she was white.
She looked black but she was white?
It's not the color of her skin,
That she's being judge by, but the seed of your father
William Shakespeare?
un- unDOUBTEDLY. BLACK.
without question
-Abraham Lincoln
-that's still in debate
What do you mean?
You don't know if he's black or white? (Pewds) I love how confident he is.
Christopher Columbus
Whose way Henry the a black? What if they judge it from yeah you?
Fun drink hot girls you're hot treat more expensive cars a street money you in a tuxedo
Drink drink drink liquor dragon punch what they do in a Santino vodka drink drink drink big doggy pudding boards Athena
*this is a ducking mess*
Please drink responsibly
*laught your way out Pewd*
So truth
Because you have to put that thing in there. God these are so awkward all right one
Okay, one three three donates $5 hello from Sweden, so I have been watching GDQ for two years now and today
I just found out that my grandpa died two hours ago
from three different types of cancer.
nooo...
No-ooo.. awww nooo..
It's a Vr game
Well done. That's fine that has to be stage four that is pretty good well done
oh
That's great. Oh
Hell, yeah
Did you laugh? Oh did you lose? WWWOOOWWW!!!
Hopefully this didn't get copyright strike check out in the description in the video if you want to check it out
They'll they may get a strike, but at least you won't get me junk and media. That's right. I'm calling you
I what you gonna do copyright this what oh I bet. You want to I bet you're trembling off
Do we have the intellectual property of this one? Nah? I said no not today
Leave a like if you liked and leave a like if you don't thank you, I'm your host killer keemstar
But it's wrong with me. Thank you guys so much for watching and as always
saryunaja(?WTF did you just say Pewd?)